many years ago in a kingdom chord bro
lot there lived a brave knight by the
name of sir PewDiePie he was king at cos
and Queen Maya's most valuable Knight
from the square table one day King at
cos summoned sir pewdiepie to his
chamber to ask for a favor sir pewdiepie
both I and Queen Maya believe that you
are the only person we can trust with
this mission you must find the sword
named Stephano and use it to slay the
dragon cryotic King and car instructed
this was a hurdle slaying the dragon cry
a tic only a madman would do such a
thing
at first sir pewdiepie refused
vigorously but then king ed car said
something that sparked his interest if
you successfully slayed the dragon and
save the princess locked in the tower
you will be able to marry her
how could he resist such an offer
everyone knew the princess looked in the
tower was the most beautiful princess in
all of the land skin like ivory eyes the
color of chocolate and a lovely deep
voice I will find the sword slay the
dragon and save the princess before
sundown tomorrow sir pewdiepie
proclaimed throwing his fist in the air
as if the battle had already been won I
am glad to hear it
the king said with a smile but please
allow me to send you with a few others
for backup and this backup happened to
be Marcia a beautiful and talented
alchemist who knew her way with magic
and the wood elf him the wick what it
makes you sound like she knows her way
with magic and me like do you see how I
just read that that threw me off okay
this backup happened to be Marcia a
beautiful and talented Alchemist who
knew her way with magic and the wood elf
Martin the track to find the sword was
no
in perilous many trials and tribulations
stood in their way the pit Abdul's the
tomb of malice and even the field of
fabulous but nothing stood in the way of
sir beauty pie and his truth he reached
the large rock that held the mighty
sword Stephano and grasped its handle
victoriously i sir pewdiepie of bro
alert proclaimed this sword is mine
he yelled as he pulled at the sword and
pulled at the sword and folded the sword
again no matter how many times he tried
the sword would not budge marzia walked
up to the weapon and swiftly hold it out
with one tug before handing it to the
Knights
oh wait is this your only line yeah this
is my one way though I need to sound
like very like really sound really
chipper what a jovial sight to see sir
pewdiepie are you not the strongest in
the land your way to get at that side
okay it was fine we shall see who's
strong when I slay the dragon he
proclaimed they traveled another few
weeks before reaching the castle where
the princess lived they snuck through
the gates and met with a 300-foot horror
that was the cryotank dragon sir just
hanging out you know
alright here we go they raised their
weapons and stared into the white face
of the dragon before charging at full
speed Christ's Maps
because he knew all too well of the
bright nights falling I'm glad you came
I love Swedish meatballs for dinner dad
cried mode yet
[Music]